hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to bad dream coma now
this is probably gonna be the last
episode of this game and unless I try to
go back and do the bad and neutral
endings but I don't even know what those
would entail because there's such a
different route that you could take in
the game if you were violin bloody but
here the birds are there the birds are
here hello Birds hi hope I don't punch
you I wouldn't mean it if I did
lovely dusk ah nothing here okay I'll
I'll be on my way Birds farewell okay
that disappeared
oh hi doggy oh you want a sausage this
sausage oh I made friends with the Bucci
the birds are in their nests and the
bees are not there but that's okay oh
the birds love me they love this is less
friendly I mean the birds are still
there so that's nice hello hi thanks for
help my friend if it hadn't been for you
I'd be waiting in line forever you're a
good person you got it buddy this is
weird but alright you got it
so who lives here in born anybody Skoosh
okay down I go then I don't have a Keith
oh never mind yes I do
alright you know go here all right I get
it
so where does he go he go there birdy
tell me where key go it's okey for mail
Oh key for door ah this door the non
mirror dimension or I guess technically
oh good my friendly bathroom am I gonna
do in this wonderful bathroom go take
some toilet paper apparently that's what
I needed from this bathroom gonna break
it enter into someone's house and then
key again Windex glass cleaner I can use
glass later on that and then I can wipe
it off with the toilet paper oh I'm a
genius okay fine then so we're over here
now but what does that mean living room
I've went to the hospital I wasn't done
exploring but I'm at the hospital
oh six five three five one one six five
seven Oh what was that number six 375
101 hey I got it okay six oh that's how
you get back here nice okay but I
thought there was anything I actually
needed here is that weird hammer this
okay there was nothing that I needed
here but that's how I get back
oh six three seven five one one I did
remember it okay well it's time to go
back to the hospital
hello lovely day
it's beautiful gorgeous in here oh no
not a patient in sight everyone is
shining much brighter which is
disturbing how can I help you it's
awfully clean in here all the mount
still a whole lot of chicken leg but ok
hello oh no the porns gone oh hey kid
have you found my parents
not quite I haven't been to the
graveyard yeah it must be somewhere if
you find out anything I'll be here
alrighty kid the nurse is very nice that
she is alrighty then I'll just be on my
way that doors finally not boarded up
hey nurse how's it going really
do you need it really what what did I do
I got no use for it now matches gloves
crowbar I wouldn't give you a sausage
but I don't have that you can't go in
there
why not there's no one there do you need
anything I'm here you Nia I want to go
in there lady I was told you were very
nice but this is the opposite of that
kind of treatment that I would expect
out of a very nice person Fineman oh I
guess I'll go outside then screw Toledo
hey birdy you happy think about nice
things okay I can't write down just
remote I went into that without gloves
but I got a flower so that's nice
someone's got to want this flower right
I got a flower wants a flower
nurse nurse you want a flower is that
for me yeah it is
I'm a charmer you know and I'm not
telling you shut up I'm awfully nice
thank you thank you I'll look for a
flaws oh thank you okay what's the point
of being here there whoa there be
nothing in there oh hi hello have you
seen my teddy bear you need help there's
no one there god damn it there's a vaaz
but it's got a hole in it oh do I gotta
get you something else nice what's up I
miss my parents
what's up have you seen my teddy bear
just kind of Oz anybody seen the FA's
around here something that can be used a
boss like Vaz esque even I'll take Vaz
esque oh hi hello has someone called me
Oh didn't mean to yeah someone did oh
yeah someone really did okay I'm in here
now hi hello who are you
Hey have you found any information you
seem awfully calm do you know how to get
out of here no damn it anyway
come with me I want to show you
something I don't know if I want to
follow you I never trusted you to begin
with
look around you everything looks more
friendly since you came here it's not a
nightmare anymore now it's just a dream
it's not worse than in the real world
perhaps it's time to accept this
situation it's time to appreciate what
we have instead of chasing the
impossible to live here or there what's
the difference the most important thing
is to be happy look at the difference
you've made the this world with your
good deeds you gave us hope and
motivation to do our best
it's the highest time to live a normal
life thank you my friend no don't do
that no I don't accept this reality oh
the door no oh god no don't do this you
look like something happened do you feel
good no I don't feel good okay all right
then
oh okay are we not gonna explain the kid
and his Creed in this whole game there's
something to that I know there is it was
two happy-go-lucky that was too happy
too lucky it was too happy-go-lucky
that can't be right oh no no there had
to be something else there what have you
got devious route I didn't go back to
the Graveyard I didn't see where his
parents were there was so many other
ways that you could play that my god
there was so much more it was so weird
because the happy ending is the one that
I didn't want
although Warley I guess yes it's a good
it's a good way to end a story to know
that the the world that you're in is
only escapable when you accept the
reality of the situation and try to be
at peace with yourself I get that I
understand it when you wake up in the
coma and the an scene that's you win
waking up from the coma because it is so
like you went into this world and and
maybe this world was all not real to
begin with and maybe the house was you
maybe the child was you your childhood
self maybe that was all you and you're
fighting with yourself to try to beat
the reality of it but I still want to
know more so anyway that is bad dream
coma I love that that was great I
thought it was so much fun to go through
that and try to explore if your nook and
cranny I'm gonna do one more episode of
this and that episode is gonna be me
blasting through the bad routes
I'm gonna see what happens when I punch
every bird punch every spider punch
everybody that comes my way and also
cheated everything I do that's what I'm
gonna do and I'm gonna see what that
leads to because there's more to this
and I like the depth I love the
attention to detail I really like it
some of the puzzles were a bit
infuriating but hey my big brain got
through it eventual
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think of
this down in the comments below I really
want to know what you think because this
game is cool but also man there's a lot
to it so thanks again and as always I
will see you
[Music]